trying to win that age 5.0 and it's not
an easy threat to combat you give a
check black simply steps up with the
King to F7
and Rook G5 is uh coming up
yeah I like it I mean he he's yeah okay
well a bit of repetitional positions
there but is there any tricks now with
this pin here the king oh my God Simon I
think that's it handshakes
is made in Baku as the 18 year old
pragnananda advances to the finals
to fight against Magnus Carlsen for the
fide World Cup Fabiano caruana will play
against abasov in the fight for the
third place what a moment this is for
pragnananda taking down Hikaru Nakamura
taking down Arjun aragassi and today he
wins his match against the world number
three Fabiano caruana
wow
18 years old and he is now confirmed
confirmed to be the third youngest ever
player to be guaranteed a spot in the
candidates the way to become world
champion behind Bobby Fisher the legend
of American chess and Magnus Carson
Prague is walking in their footsteps we
know the final what a final that's going
to be